this is a follow-up video to a vlog that
made a couple of weeks ago about my
favorite apps that I use my PhD now
since making that video I've actually
started using a new app which I found
phenomenally useful and I thought you
guys should know about it I do want to
make very clear by the way that this is
not a sponsored video this isn't a
sponsored video it is it is this I've
not had any communication with the
people that make this Apple anything
like that literally I just started using
this app and I thought wow this is
really good so the app is called forest
this is what it looks like now if you
use the tomato timer app before you'll
be familiar with the concept of working
in short bursts and then you take a
break what makes forest different is
that you set your timer but when you
click go
it effectively locks your phone if
you're anything like me when you're
studying you will just be like a little
bit bored I'm going to go on Twitter and
then suddenly this like half an hour
later and you procrastinator but I'm
realizing what you're doing because it
locks your phone you can't do that now
you'll notice on the app itself there's
a tree focus there you go there's a tree
and the idea is when you start your
study timer it plants a seed and as your
timer goes on mind sets 25 minutes you
can actually set them shorter and it's
not a tree it's a bush instead as the
time ticks down on the tree grows and
grows and grows now it's said that it
kind of locks your phone it doesn't
actually lock your phone
what it does is it detects if you leave
the app whilst the time is running it
kills the tree if on the other hand you
make it through your timer and you get a
notification saying your trees grown
then it plants a tree in your forest
plot for the day so to each block of
work that you complete at the end of the
day you can look and see how many blocks
you've done and it's represented by the
number of trees but you also can see how
many blocks of work you failed at so as
well as having the motivation of trying
to keep the tree alive at the end of the
day you see how many times you got
distracted and for me it totally turned
this past week around for productivity
like I did have a massive breakthrough
in the thesis recently which I did do
what does in using this app but I can't
let that take credit for that was all me
but since that breakthrough this app has
allowed me to stay focused and
concentrated so much more than I
otherwise would've and it's because you
have that um the idea that if you lose
motivation and you get distracted you
killer
which I personally don't want to do but
also knowing that if you do complete the
work then you have like a nice visual
representation of it and the best part
about it is it's free that I use the
free version you can download like a
premium version which doesn't have ads
that's the only annoying thing about the
default app is that you have ads on it
but honestly this has changed my
productivity so so much and there are
other features I haven't talked about
like you can unlock trees with currency
that you get from completing sessions so
your plot gets more diverse as you go on
and you can change the length of timers
and you can change all kinds of settings
or whatever like the best thing you can
do is because it's free just download it
and have a look if you are studying or
even to be honest if you just want to
concentrate more on work like replying
to emails I get some sessions earlier
where I was like right I've got to reply
to a bunch of messages put a couple of
trees town let's do this it's it's so
useful honestly and the best way to see
if it's view is just to try it again I'm
not being paid for this at all all right
let it even though I'm making this video
I just thought it's great if you do want
to download it then I'll put links down
there to the Android store and Apple
Store other other stores I don't even
know and that's it that's all I wanted
to say I just wanted make a quick video
it's called forest again go check it out
because I really enjoyed using it if you
want to check out that vlog where I talk
about other apps that you use you can
check that out over here I think and if
you're new here hi and you like this
video then well you should like it but
also there's a button here to subscribe
if you want